make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
okay so picking up with darkseid war act
2 which we never did here on comics
explain
we are currently joining with the
aftermath of darkseid dying and this is
where people are kind of panicking and
people don't really know what to do
right i mean darkseid kind of
represented this immutable
indestructible force that existed out
there in the multiverse and when his
with his death which was thought to be
impossible
people are just kind of shocked by it
and so the first person to really
express the the concern over what's
happened
is the black racer is the flash and it's
one of these things where you would
expect the response of barry allen to be
somebody get this off of me right
somebody get this thing off of me i
don't want to be bonded to it i want to
be away from this you know i
value life i don't want to be bonded to
a being that
literally embodies death but instead you
know you kind of have this response by
mr miracle and saying that like once you
know the aspect of death is bonded to a
host
it cannot be undone until death leaves
that host or that physical host dies or
something along those lines and the
responsibility is no you don't
understand i want to control this
right i don't want it i don't want to
get rid of it i want to control this
right so he is more or less being
corrupted
by this death entity that's taken over
him from there you switch over to
superman and lex luthor and again
superman's corrupted by the fact that he
was thrown in these solar pits and it
brings out every bit of
of anger and and wrath that he has not
in the sense that he's driven to kill
lex luthor but in the sense that he kind
of seizes him and says okay so like
here's what's going to happen
right like i know you want me to get you
out of this place you're not going
anywhere right you're staying here
because despite the efforts of lex
luthor to prove himself as being a good
guy
superman still still views him to be a
bad guy he still views him
as being a villain that he's simply just
biding his time until he commits some
campaign that's designed to allow him to
you know conquer metropolis or you know
kill superman or something along those
lines now the reality
is that we as the reader know lex luthor
legitimately is trying to be a good guy
like he legitimately is trying to turn
over a new leaf and the funny thing is
that this lack of trust is not a one-off
from dark side war in fact when you pick
up a dc rebirth and you get into dan
jurgens the adventures of uh what is it
superman and lois lane or whatever it
was called the one where you kind of had
like the pre-crisis superman kind of
hanging out with the new 52 superman and
the new 52 universe then even then he
doesn't trust lex luthor but even then
he sees him as you know a guy who will
always be a bad guy so
it's kind of interesting to see this
reformation of lex luthor but nobody
believing in him because it's one of
these things where you kind of feel bad
for his character it's like damn like
lex luthor's really trying to be a good
guy and superman still won't give him
any slack but then you remember all the
stuff lex luthor's done
and then you're kind of like okay so
like superman has a legitimate reason to
be skeptical of this guy like lex
luther's always kind of been a dick
but ultimately superman just leaves him
there right he just kind of knocks him
knocks him to the side
and leaves him there and kind of gives
him this ultimatum if you come back to
earth i will tear you apart right i will
i'll kill you i'll crush you
just like i did with your armor and so
from there you switch over to batman and
two to hal jordan and this is where
things kind of got a little murky with
bruce wayne then hal jordan you know
where batman's like dark side's dead the
war is over it's time to go home
the response of hal is what about the
anti-monitor right and the response to
batman is he touched the anti-life
equation right that turned him into the
monster that he is
now he's ejecting it from his body and
so when that's done he's gonna go back
to being who he was before
let's just split let's go our own way
and batman actually
intends to take the mobius chair back to
gotham and then use it as a means to
fight crime in gotham now here's the
problem with that right here's the
biggest issue with that izakana
stretches the limits of what batman
believes
as a superhero right whether you agree
with him or disagree with him the idea
behind batman
is it would be great to say one step
ahead
of what people intend to do but the the
problem with batman
with this mobius chair is most likely it
would corrupt him and push him to the
point that he would start getting
involved in pre-crime
given your habits given my intellect i
can deduce what crime or what you're
most likely going to do next so i'm
suddenly going to arrest you before that
happens now i am not necessarily
opposed to that not necessarily in the
sense of like arresting people before
they commit crimes but simply just
having the mobius chair and sitting down
and saying what have i been doing all
this time
why am i letting superheroes go letting
super villains go free i should just
arrest these guys and throw them in jail
but you can't really
arrest a person for a crime they haven't
committed yet and so because of that
it would probably push batman to the
point that he might become a bit of a
dictator and depending on how he does it
i may or may not agree with it the waste
being depicted here
would most likely be a circumstance that
i wouldn't necessarily agree with
and even hal jordan is just kind of like
you know that's kind of a crazy thing
but batman ultimately sends him on his
path and says like you have to go do
your own thing right you have to go to
oahu
because the forces of the parademons are
descending on owa it's the single most
powerful place
in the entirety of the universe and the
parademons have no leader anymore
there's no dark side and they are
inherently drawn to power
so it's one of these things where it's
like go and do your own thing now that
of course
leads into the hal jordan uh dark side
war one shot right so the same thing
with barry allen figuring himself out
about the flash
uh you know the the black racer and so
on that leads into the barry allen into
the flash one shot and so from there you
pick back up with lex luthor who's
basically discovered by adora and she's
the leader of the forgotten people now
here's the thing about this
um i'm not aware that adora had ever
been featured
in the new 52 or even really anything
like post-crisis
um the only adora that i really know of
is like the old school
character who was like smitten for lex
luthor basically but she was somebody
who existed back in like the 60s and 70s
right and she was published back then so
i'm not aware that there's like any new
version of adora floating around out
there and even jeff john
seems to be kind of hand-wavy about it
in terms of how it's written you know
he's like well who you know lexi was
like who are you and she's like if you
knew if you knew of us then you know how
how impressive we are right so it's kind
of like ah there are people who exist
and that's basically it that's really
the only explanation that we get and in
fact
the idea behind the forgotten people
seems to be that they're just one of the
tribes that exist out there on
apocalypse that have somehow managed to
escape
the rule of pot of dark side or they
just kind of
biding their time until darkseid's death
and the latter
seems to be the case because she talks
about a blind prophet who basically
writes that the night the dark side dies
that a human will appear on apocalypse
and that human would change everything
right it'd be the greatest hero
from the world that they hail from from
a place called metropolis they would
have saved this world
multiple times they would be an orphan
they would be humbled by
by being the child of farmers they would
seek truth and embodiment of justice
she's describing superman is basically
what she's describing granted he's not
really human but the fact that he
desires to be one of them and they adopt
him into their ranks he might as well be
the other thing about this though and
that's what's kind of ironic is it could
also be lex luthor granted he's not
really the son of a farmer but
everything else that he's aspiring to
he's aspiring to become what superman is
whether he wants to admit it or not
that's what he's shooting for and so
when she asked the question
are you this man his response is yes i
am now the indication here is he's kind
of doing it in a duplicitous way
where it's like uh yeah yeah of course
i'm the guy you're looking for
definitely uh what do you need me to do
you know
that kind of a thing you know that kind
of a you know villainous
sort of thing that he's doing but of
course the the people around him bow to
him
but adora does not and she's like he
hasn't earned that right yet and so
following that you pick
pick back up with billy batson who has
this kind of crisis now this goes into
the shazam
god of god storyline and it actually
left a lot hanging right in the sense
that there's this kind of
discussion going on among these gods
that power shazam
some of them saying like this boy will
not be my power you know some of them
saying like he'll be my vessel so
the gods are kind of fighting amongst
each other now this goes into
the old gods abandoning shazam and the
new gods taking its place
right but the one of the big issues and
we can we can remaster the one shot if
you guys want me to
one of the big issues that we ran into
with this is that there was a lot left
hanging
in the sense of what happened to these
various beings who possessed shazam
right because
after this you don't see shazam in dc
rebirth right you don't see him until
we got the newer issue that we did where
superboy prime came back that's all you
get we don't get anything between now
and then he's just
nowhere to be seen we have no idea
whatever happened to the to the guys
that empowered him or anything like that
and dc never really bothered to explain
it a lot of it was because it seemed to
be that their main focus was
let's just rebirth everything right
let's just like fix this whole new 52
initiative let's make it what it's
supposed to be
and that was the main focus everything
else kind of fell to the wayside what
you guys saw
with shazam between like the the end of
new 52
going into dc rebirth and everything
they came after dc's done that multiple
times that was the struggle of power
girl post-crisis
after crisis on defenders hawkman like
all that kind of stuff has happened
multiple times right stuff just slips
through the cracks which i think is
really more a reflection of a lack of
organization than anything else but
while shazam essentially takes off all
you really have left are like cyborg
and you've got like jessica cruz you
know and like i said you only really
and you have wonder woman you got like a
couple people here and of course this
leads to the remnants of the forces of
darkseid seizing onto them and kind of
initiating a great big huge fight now
the the cool thing to come out of this
is that picking back up with lex luthor
he's taken by the forgotten people and
and basically brought to this place as
kind of a great big huge power harvester
and the reason why is that
when darkseid died his omega sanction
the source of all of his power
left his body and came arriving back to
to the planet of apocalypse and the
reason why he seemed to be a kind of
fail-safe
that when this happens that it'll stay
there until it's bonded to a new host
whether it's darkseid or somebody else
and so when the mega effect comes back
because lex luthor is hooked
up to this whole system it'll bond to
him and if he truly is the person that
the blind prophet's prophecy foretold
then it'll bond to him successfully and
lex luthor will in effect
become the new dark side and so what you
end up doing is switching back over to
the
back over to earth with grail and with
mariana black and while the two of them
are talking we end up learning that the
the
anti-monitor or mobius has put himself
in a kind of cocoon then he's wrapped
himself in this cocoon
for the purpose of of getting himself
cleared up right of allowing him
to purge himself of the anti-life
equation and so where the bonding
process with lex luthor is successful
and lex luthor does become
what is in effect the new dark side the
fight between the forces of wonder woman
and cyborg and mr miracle and
the justice league that's left and the
forces of of like steppenwolf
and and those guys ends up coming into
full fray when you have them all just
sort of
battling each other and so when the
forces of wonder woman battle basically
the forces of of kanto and all those
guys you know the remnants of
apocalypse's elite fighting force
the the battle sort of you know
interrupted to a degree by the arrival
of big barta now the reality is that big
barda and scot-free
are in effect on a honeymoon
following their marriage but no one's
supposed to know that they got married
right because granny goodness the leader
of the furies if she found out
she would come hunting for for big barta
and scot-free and try to kill them both
and they would never relent that's the
thing to understand
they would never relent like they would
never ever back off
or anything like that they would always
come after them even if they were
defeated they would go back they would
regroup and they would come back again
and so scot-free and big bartender would
spend their entire lives
essentially looking over their shoulders
and so where she comes in
big varda immediately kills kanto and
then in turn she turns to the rest of
the forces that she kind of tells him
look like
back off right you stay away we stay
away darkseid's dead
there's nobody giving you direction or
instruction anymore you're not being
lorded over
by any kind of of multiversal god demon
entity whatever or anything like that
just
go let us live in peace and the response
of lashina and all them is
no we are not going to you chose to
forgo the
the black oath of the furies you
betrayed us
and we will never forget that betrayal
we will always come for you we will
always come back and get you and so
following that you kind of jump back to
grail and mariana black and the whole
discussion between the
between the two of them is the idea of
the anti-monitor purging himself of the
anti-life equation of mobius reverting
back to his previous form and that's
when you see this discussion that goes
on
where she kind of reveals that was the
whole intention behind it all
that while she's talking of course
superman arrives back on the scene and
immediately goes to attack
steve trevor right because it's kind of
like you know to a degree you're
you're squeezing in on my girl right
because superman and wonder woman were a
thing at one point in time but he kind
of shows back up on the scene
and so while all that's going on
shazam's basically gone out doing his
own thing
flash is having this existential crisis
in relation to the black racer the
justice league is just kind of all over
the place right either they're
incapacitated they're hanging on by a
string
or they're out basically out and about
having nothing to do
except deal with their own personal
crises that with the with the
anti-monitor
finally purging the anti-life equation
from himself grail takes it right and
that's when we realized this was all
based on the idea
of her achieving the anti-life equation
that's what she was shooting for
this whole war was initiated by her even
her mom's campaign
was seeing the death of darkseid was
kind of modified and deviated by grail
herself
she instigated this entire conflict so
she could seize the anti-life equation
for herself
and the reason why the whole motivation
behind this is she felt like death was
too good for darkseid that she intended
to basically bond or at least does
intend to find a way to resurrect
darkseid and then bond the anti-life
equation to him and then in turn
subjugate darkseid so with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you